yo when uh you had mr cartoon do your
belly okay uh one of the most iconic
rap tattoos ever yeah
was that on tour yes yes yeah yeah so
which tour was this anger what a
management tour is it the first one
i'm not for sure
but uh
man this dude was she was touring he was
doing everybody so
you know he was so booked up that you
know what i'm saying like i had to make
it i made an appointment i think he had
just did 50. he was tattooing everybody
and everybody he was talented every day
somebody was getting tatted
so it was my time he was going to do my
stomach
and uh
he said what do you want i said i wanna
i wanna collage to detroit i want
the buildings in the background the
coney islands liquor stores the pit
bulls
they're just grimacing traits okay
so he drew it
he drew it on me first mm-hmm and then i
i had to go perform you know because
this is a big festival and [ __ ] overseas
so i went and performed rock the show
sweated it off came back and
i didn't know that the worst thing in
the world you could do
is get a tattoo with open sweat and
pores oh so before i asked him i said yo
yo
is this tattoo gonna hurt
he said no man you know you're good
you're good
so then when he started doing the [ __ ]
like everybody pulling their cameras out
and [ __ ] cause they're like i'm like
that's a tough place too i said i
thought you said this [ __ ] wasn't gonna
hurt
he said yeah
it's not gonna hurt me
damn yeah so i just i had to sit there
and pain bro that [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
crazy man but
i was told they tell me once you start
you can't stop
that that'll be like yeah you got to
finish it like being a [ __ ] well
imagine you
torn with half a tattoo on your belly
quarter of a tattoo
they would have said that's bizarre i
couldn't get away with it yeah that's
true
no but i had to do it man they would i
would have been a [ __ ] if i would have
finished it right